- Guys I'm so excited!
- It's a little wiggly.
- It's okay, they'll have to deal with it.
♫ Ass ass ass ass ass ass ♫
I'm here with Alexis G. Zall.
How do you describe
yourself to other people?
- Wow!
♫ Don't forget me, I'm-- ♫
- Yeah.
- Wow, wait to dive right in.
Human being?
- Human being is always appreciated.
Not everyone considers
everyone human beings,
which is a huge bummer, but,
I consider you a human being.
- Thank you, same to you.
♫ Don't forget me, I beg ♫
- I have a million questions for you.
- Great.
- How old are you?
- I'm 17.
- 17.
- Also, I feel like I should
say, I'm a weird teen.
♫ Ass ass ass ass ass ♫
- Do you consider yourself an old soul?
- No.
♫ Don't forget me ♫
- Ew, old!
- I think I'm like a
good 35 on the inside?
Like a spicy 35.
- What do you think about
these singers and celebrities?
Demi Lovato.
- She exists, and it
doesn't make my life worse.
- Selena Gomez.
- I'm a fan.
- A fan?
- A fan.
- Taylor Swift?
- Oh, so into it!
Will you please calm down?
- Can you calm the (snare hit) down?
What do you think about Chipotle?
("Kashmir" by Led Zeppelin)
- Okay, I like Chipotle.
♫ Don't forget me ♫
I think Chipotle has a
really good business model.
- Which is get every Youtuber to talk
about how much they love Chipotle?
- Sure!
(applause)
Beyonce has Illuminati.
Youtube has Chipotle.
- And hoverboards.
- Yes!
- No, I'm sorry that's Vine.
(booing)
What is your Youtube pet peeve?
- So, there's a lot of like
(snare hit) boys online.
- Yeah, what is that?
- In my opinion, there's two
types of (snare hit) boys.
- Okay.
- There's the (snare hit) boy that's
just like an overall party douchebag.
- Okay.
- And then the more fun kind
of (snare hit) boy is these
Internet boys who build their careers
on their fans wanting to (snare hit) them.
- Oooh!
♫ You ♫
That makes sense!
- That's like the more interesting kind,
so I won't name any names
but like (beep) is one.
I think one of my biggest pet peeves is
it's a strong way to make money.
It bothers me when boys don't
know how to do it right.
- Oh, okay.
- If you're like a sloppy (snare hit) boy,
like what are you doing?
♫ Who let the dogs out ♫
At least be really good at being horrible.
- That's a great piece of advice.
♫ Don't for-- ♫
For all of you aspiring (snare hit) boys
out there, do it right!
- Don't tweet "retweet for a DM"
heartshaped biting lip selfie at 11 a.m..
Everyone's in school!
- What is your most
used acronym right now?
Or phrase, or just some
piece of like jargon slang?
- I'm really into the word dandy.
I also say rock and roll a lot.
I don't even know where that came from.
- Uh, I mean from the '60s.
What has been your best
collaboration experience with people?
("Kashmir" by Led Zeppelin)
- Ooh, I mean, right now.
♫ I bless the rains down in Africa ♫
- Favorite social media app?
- I'd say Snapchat.
- Yeah.
- Definitely a fan of Snapchat.
- I also think it's where
people are the most raw.
- Yeah, 'cause you don't care.
Also, I know like my
younger Youtuber friends
none of our parents know
how to go on Snapchat.
- Oh!
- My mom's on Twitter,
so she sees everything.
- Do you have a favorite
person on social media?
Does it change from social
media to social media?
- I'm honestly a fan of like
a classic (snare hit) boy.
- Okay.
("Someone Like You" by Adele)
- Don't tweet "retweet for a DM"
heartshaped biting lip selfie at 11 a.m..
At least be really good at being horrible.
- Everyone on Youtube
loves Chipotle so much
that I started to have a theory that
it was like a form of Scientology.
Piece of advice you would give to
fellow teenagers out
there on social media.
- Don't over (beeping).
So many teen Youtubers
are just really clean,
like to the point where
it's not (beeping).
- Yeah.
- So don't do that.
- Okay, that makes sense.
Now, a piece of advice
to the older generation.
- Listen.
- Okay.
♫ I bless the rains down in Africa ♫
Oh.
Well thank you for answering
some of my questions.
- Anytime.
- And guys, we went and we shot
a video over on Alexis's channel
so make sure you check it out!
Go check out the video on Alexis's channel
and go follow her on social media.
Where can we find you on
all your social media?
- @alexisgzall, my name,
Z as in zebra, A-L-L.
- Perfect, I don't know.
♫ Don't forget me, I beg ♫
Click on her face, there will be
some sort of annotation there.
- What a group of teens!
- Oh my god, how appropriate.
There's a group of teens.
- Like two ways flannels!
- There's teens, you guys.
Drive away!
Really curious about the (snare hit) boys.